we will touch on that briefly
and then we will move on to a
very important chapter of the
book which is very unique about
this book actually. And that is
about and that is the chapter
with regards to the issue of
names. And the kind of words
that the prophet would use. And
the kinds of words that he
would not use. the kind of
things that he would say and
the kind of things that he
would prohibit people from
saying etcetera. So, it's a
very unique chapter in this
book and it's actually one of
my favorite chapters in this
book. We were discussing last
week the days that the prophet
would fast or encourage
fasting. We've mentioned that
Fasting, anytime is
permissible. There certain days
which are not permissible to
fast on their own There are
certain days which are not
permissible to fast at all and
the rest is open season. A
person can fast anytime they
like. To begin, we'd to
discuss the days that he
encouraged a person fast. The
day of Ashura, which is the
tenth day of the first month of
the Islamic calendar we
discussed that in detail last
week. Also, he fasted and
encouraged fasting the day of
Arafa which is the ninth day of
the 12th month of the Islamic
calendar. That is the ninth
day. Of the so, it's the day
before Eid, right? That day,
the day of Arufa, the prophet
was asked about the reward of a
person who fasts the day of
Ashhura and the day of Arafah.
He said, the day of Arafah, it
will expiate sin of a year
previous and a year to come and
as for the day of Ashura, it
will expiate the sins of a year
past, right? So, we understand
and we surmise from this that
fasting the day of Arafa is
superior to fasting the day of
Ashhura. We discuss this in
detail. wise, the prophet
was narrated to a fasted
Mondays and Thursdays. This was
a common practice and very
rarely did he ever
not fast these two days of the
week. Likewise, he encouraged
fasting three days a week,
three days a month, excuse me.
So, he encouraged just in
general, fast three days a
month, any 3 days. And it's
preferable that of these three
days, it'd be the thirteenth,
the 14th, and the fifteenth of
the Islamic Lunar Calendar.
Likewise, it is permissible to
fast any day but it is not
permissible to fast every day
If a person fasts every single
day, this is not permissible
for a person to do. As the
prophet has mentioned, Mansa
whoever fasts all the time,
then they have neither fasted
nor have broken their fast. So,
this is not something which is
of the prophet practice and as
a matter of fact, ad monished
his companions. Abdullah
used to fast every day and he
prohibited him from doing this.
Likewise, likewise, is the
issue of fasting on Saturday
alone. Just choosing Saturday
by itself to fast. This is not
permissible. Ibn He says here
and
[Silence]
Cathy Ibn al Kaim, you know,
scholars that are known for
their for their in the science
of Hadith. If they say, it has
been narrated, usually that
means that the narration is
weak. The difference between
saying and it and the prophet
said or
or saying he said or he
authentically said or in indeed
he said something that but
when it's in this way it's
been narrated that he said that
means it's usually weak Here
says and it's been narrated
that the prophet used to fast
on Saturdays and Sundays often.
This narration is collected by
Imam Ahmed and it's an
inauthentic narration. It's a
weak narration. It's not
narrated that he used to, it's
not authentic that he would
fast on Saturdays. As a matter
of fact, Ibn ul Kaim says, this
narration is weak. Never.
And it's also been narrated
that the prophet prohibited
fasting on Saturdays, okay?
This narration is different
upon amongst the scholars of
Hadith. Some scholars view this
narration to be authentic.
Meaning that he prohibited a
person fast on Saturday.
However, there are other
narrations that articulate that
it's permissible to fast on
Saturday. As long as you fast a
day before or a day after. So,
you can't fast it alone by
itself. There's a narration in
a Sunan which is authentic that
the prophet said, do not fast
on Friday alone unless you fast
a day before it or day after
it. So, if I wanted to fast
Friday and fast the day after,
I'd be fasting on Saturday and
that's permissible. So, fasting
it together with Friday or
Sunday is permissible. Fasting
Saturday alone by itself is
impermissible. Likewise,
Friday, fasting alone by
itself. This is not
permissible. A person must fast
Thursday or Saturday along with
it. So, those are two days of
the week that a person should
can fast under the condition
that they fast the day before
it or a day after it. This is
not Speaking, these narrations
are not speaking about fasting
days which are obligatory. What
do I mean by that? Let's say a
person has days of Ramadan that
they missed. Can they fast one
day to make up for Ramadan on
Friday or on Saturday? Yes.
Because that's an obligatory
fast, right? Let's say a person
has an expiation. They have to
fast 3 days, right? do they
can they fast Friday on its own
or Saturday on its own? Yes,
because it's an obligatory
fast. But if it is a fast, that
is not obligatory, right? It's
just, it's just extra
voluntary, then you have to
fast the day before or after.
Friday and Saturday only. Now,
what if a person just fast
Saturday or just fast Sunday or
Friday? Is there fast
acceptable? what appears is
that the fast itself is
acceptable but the person is
not followed the sunnah, right?
It's also impermissible for a
person to fast on the day of
Eid. It's not permissible to
fast on the first day of
Shawwal. It's not permissible
to fast on. The tenth day of
the okay? So the Eid we have
two Eids, right? The first Eid
is the first day of Shawwal.
Right? Ramadan's over. The
first day of Shawwal. That's
the day of Eid. Right? The
second Eid, the major Eid is
the tenth day of the Hajjjah,
the after, the day after Yom
Arafa, right? That tenth day of
the 12th month, that is the day
of Eid. It's not permissible to
fast that day. Also, in the
correct opinion, it is
impermissible to fast during
the days of Tashiriak. I am a
Teshiriak. What are the days of
they are the eleventh, 12th,
and 13th days of the of the
12th month. That's the day
after Eid, the three days that
come after Eid alpa. These days
are called right? The prophet
said,
he said these days, meaning the
days of Tashriach, 11th, 12th,
and 13th of the they are days
of eating and drinking and
remembrance of Allah. And this
is why days are considered part
of the Eid, right? A person can
slaughter anyone of these days.
If you want to slaughter for
you can slaughter on the tenth,
11th, 12th, or 13th day. All of
that is considered part of the
Eid. So, really the days of
Tashrik are an extension of the
day of Eid. Eid al Abha. So,
it's not permissible to fast
during the days of Teshiriq,
right? Another time when it is
in permissible to fast is
Yomashek the day of doubt. Why
is it referred to as the day of
doubt? Well, on the 29th day of
Shabben, right? The 29th day of
Shaben. We're looking around
for the moon. We're not sure if
today is the first day of
Ramadan or if tomorrow is the
first day of Ramadan. So, just
to be safe, I'm going to fast
that day. That is not
permissible. It is
impermissible to fast on the
day. The of doubt. It's
referred to as the day of doubt
because we doubt. We're
doubting whether it's or is it
Ramadan, right? This is
referred to as the day of
doubt. So, a person says, well,
I just want to cover my bases
and be safe? No. Person cannot
fast that day on his own just
to be safe. Because Ramadan
only starts when the moon has
been sited and people have
acknowledged its siding. Pay
attention to the wording I'm
using. When the moon is sited,
and people have acknowledged
its sighting, right? What does
that mean? Why why this kind of
wording? This wording is
important. because the month
doesn't officially begin until
it becomes acknowledged by
everybody that the month has
begun. So, the moon itself is
not the month of Ramadan or the
any month. The moon is an
indication of the month. There
is a very detailed issue here.
What does this mean? So, let's
say it's Chaben and I see the
crescent for Ramadan, right?
and so,
I go and I I inform the
powers that be or what have you
and they say, no, it's it's not
Ramadan. You didn't see it.
It's not acknowledged. Do I
fast that day alone? Or do I
not fast? Remember the wording
we used? The crescent is not
the month. The crescent is an
indication of the month. The
month is only the month when it
becomes acknowledged by the
majority of people. Right? So
there's no instance where I'm
fasting Ramadan and noone else
is fasting. So, even if I
happen to see the moon but
nobody fasts because they do
not acknowledge that the month
of Ramadan has begun because
they think that I didn't see it
properly or what have you. I
would not fast that day on my
own. I would not fast and I
would begin fasting when the
people fast. Because the
prophet said, in he said,
to the is fasting is when you
all fast and breaking your fast
is when you all break your fast
and the day of slaughtering is
when you all is when you all
slaughter, right? So,
acknowledgement of the month,
this is what commences the
month. Not necessarily the
crescent itself. and so, you
know, when it's kind of
calculated that the crescent
can't really be seen by the
naked eye, but it's essentially
there, and we can see it with
telescopes and so forth, that
is not the month of Ramadan.
That is not the month yet,
because people haven't seen it.
People haven't acknowledged
its, it's its commencement,
right? So, this is referred to
as the day of doubt. Is
impermissible to fast. It's not
permissible to fast just to
cover your bases before the day
of Ramadan. Rather, we fast
when people fast. When our
community begins to fast,
that's when we fast. The more,
what is the point of the the
moon then? The crescent is an
indication of when that should
start. When that should end,
but it's not the only factor
that is into consideration when
people fast or break their
fast. Is that clear? Right? So
we see this mistake often
especially for Ramadan,
especially for Eid. You've got
some people over here fasting
and other people over here not
fasting. This this shouldn't
ever happen. Because fasting,
breaking our fast, the day of
Eid. This is a communitative
thing. It's something that
happens altogether. It's not
just an issue of dry facts. The
moon was there, wasn't there,
or that's not exactly the point
of it, right?
He says
he says and these narrations
that he would fast on Saturday
and Sunday and and other
narrations he prohibited
fasting on Saturday. He said if
we were to harmonize between
these narrations, one narration
we have him doing it and
another he we have him
prohibiting it. Then, the
prohibition means for a person
to fast Saturday on its own.
However, if you fast the day
before or a day after, it is,
it is permissible. Another
issue of brings up is the issue
of what is when a person when a
person vows to remain in the
Masjid or a particular amount
of time under certain
circumstances, under very
particular circumstances.
So, when a person makes a
decaf, there are things which
are permissible, things that
are impermissible for the
person to do. Person vows at
the calf for 10 days or of the
last ten nights of Ramadan for
instance, Then, a person, for
instance, cannot leave the
masjid, right? For, for, for
anything aside from that which
is absolutely necessary, such
as eating or drinking, or
relieving oneself, or something
of that nature. Likewise, when
a person makes a decaf, it is
not permissible for a person to
engage in any sexual conduct
while making anti calf in the
masjid. Now, the scholars
differ on Gaticaf widely differ
on it. Some scholars mention
that anti calf is only
permissible in three right?
Only permissible in Mecca,
Medina, and Al Aqsa. Those are
the only places that takes
place. Can take place in
regular misagent. This is the
opinion of however, this is not
the opinion of the majority of
the companions of the prophet
the there is a narration that
some scholars view as authentic
that is not to be done except
in three masjid, right?
Meaning, Mecca, Medina, and Al
Aqsa. This narration is
different upon amongst the
scholars and whether it's
authentic or not. however
this narration doesn't mean
that in general is absolutely
impermissible outside of these
three because we have
companions that make Atikaf in
regular massages and Honestly,
the majority of the scholars,
the scholarship of Islam, view
that is permissible in any
masjid. In any masjid, but they
say there is a condition. As
long as it is masjid in Jannah.
What is Masjid Jama? Major
Masjid, meaning a masjid that
has jummah that is done in it.
It's not just the it's not just
a masjid where they pray but
they don't do jummah. That's
just a minor masjid. That's
just a masjid that people use
to a major masjid is this
masjid where we have right
where we have President Imam
that leads salah and gives and
so forth. This is the only kind
of masjid that a person can
make at the cafen. Another
issue with regards to is the
timing. When can a person make
at decaf and how long can
they're at decaf be? The
correct opinion without delving
too deeply into the topic. Is
that is permissible anytime of
the year. Day or night and for
any amount of time. It doesn't
have to be necessarily in
Ramadan. And it doesn't
necessarily have to be when a
person is fasting. Right the
prophet made a in Shawwal. the
month after Ramadan. One year
he didn't make a in the last
ten nights. And so he made a in
10 days of Shawet. Also does a
person have to be fasting when
they make a decaf. Is it a
condition of anti calf? This is
also a difference of opinion.
Ibn's opinion is that a person
must be fasting. And he says
there's never been an aeration
that authentically clearly
states that he ever made the
while he was not fasting.
Meaning, every time he made a
calf, he was fasting. It was
during Ramadan or however, a
very strong opinion and this is
the opinion that is adopted by
Allah and his book Al Min Hajj
is that is permissible when a
person is fasting and when he's
not fasting because
he came to the prophet and
said, I vowed I would make a or
a single night in Mecca the of
Mecca, right? And so the
prophet said, fulfill your vow.
Fulfill your vow. So, he's
going to be there during the
night time, right? He's
going to be making at night. Do
we fast at night? No, fasting
is daytime activity. Therefore,
it is based on this narration.
It is permissible for a person
to make a decaf while they are
fasting or not during the
Ramadan or outside of Ramadan
as long as the conditions are
fulfilled and there's no
specific timeline set. doesn't
have to be ten whole days. It
could be less or more. Fight.
Now, we are going to get into a
very unique chapter of this
book, Zad il Maad. The chapter
regarding the issue of names
and words, and nicknames, and
language that is permissible,
and language that is
impermissible. With regards to
the sun of the prophet. So
first, we'll start with naming.
How do we name our children?
What are the best names to name
them? What names are
impermissible or haram for a
person to to give another
person? Ibn says
[Silence]
tilling and Hamam is someone
who is constantly brooding or
thinking, right? These are very
befitting names for the human
being. Human being is
constantly had it, constantly
at work, doing something, even
if they're doing nothing, then
they're doing nothing, right?
Or a person is constantly
hemme. They're constantly
thinking and stressing and and
calculating and contemplating
He says and the worst names are
Harb, which means literally war
or mora, which means very sour.
Now, the Arabs in the time of
pre-Islamic era, they would
name their children names like
this. hoping that these
children would turn out to be
as their name states. So, for
instance, they would name their
children. They would name their
son for instance, Harb. Harub
means war. Hoping that their
child would grow up to be war,
upon their enemies, right?
Likewise, they may name their
children right? Which means
extremely sour. Hoping that
they would be this way towards
their enemies, right? However,
these names are impermissible
in Islam because they
articulate about the person,
something that should not be of
his characteristic and prophet
has indicated that a name has
an effect on a person. and a
person has an effect on their
name. As mentions. If you refer
to a person by a good name,
this will instill a good nature
in that person. And if you
refer to a person with a bad
name or terrible name or a
difficult name, etcetera. This
will instill. Difficulty in
that person. It's been
indicated in the sunnah that
person's name has an effect on
how they will be right? And
it's also been narrated that he
said
at every person who is named
with a name will end up having
a portion of the meaning of
that name actualized in his
life. A person should avoid bad
names for their children. They
should choose names for their
children that will cause their
children to aspire to good
things. And honestly, it's kind
of a little bit
a little bit disheartening when
we see Muslims using names that
are not essentially Muslim
names. Naming names that naming
their children with names that
are unique and exotic and are
not traditionally names. The
prophet encouraged that we name
our children with the names of
the prophets that we name our
children with the names. Of the
prophet Muhammad that we name
our children with names that
are found in the Quran that are
found in the Sunnah. And some
of these other names that are
being used often. And some of
them are even specific to non
Muslims. This is something
which is upon deeply in Islam.
Also, the prophet said in one
narration that which translates
to to do not name your son
Yasar. Yasar means left.
Rather, we ache. the right side
is a good omen, not the left
side. Likewise, or or why?
These are names that mean he
has succeeded, he has he says
because someone may come and
say,
Naji there or there Is anyone
named Efla in your home? Anyone
named Efla meaning succeeded?
And they'll say no, there's
nobody here who has succeeded.
No, there's nobody here in this
house that has succeeded or
that has won or that has
etcetera.
goes into the meanings here He
mentions some particular names
which are impermiss which are
impermissible or that the
prophet changed, right? He
says, a woman's name, Asia,
which which means disobedient.
Now, why would a person name
his child disobedient, right?
This is the name of a female.
And the answer is that what
they meant is disobedient to
their enemies, right? This is
an impermissible name to name
your child disobedience. The
meaning, I don't see it, right?
Likewise, Barra, Barra, which
means
and and these are different
names which have foul meanings
basically.
means the father of the all
wise. He Al Hechem is not a
permissible name to have.
[Silence]
Abu Abu Abdullah, Abu Abdul
Rahman, Abu
of nickname, right? Likewise,
Abdullah, Abdul Rahman, right?
This is called a Kunya and it
has father or mother in front
of it. This is called the
Kunya.
Usually, the prophet would give
the Kunya based on a person's
eldest son. The first son,
that's where they would get
their kunya from. So, if you
have a a son, your first son,
his name is Muhammad, you're
going to be called Abu
Muhammad, right? Usually and
the female as well but that's
not always. There are
exceptions to that. For
instance, the prophet gave a to
a child that didn't have any
children, right?
He also gave Aquinia to Alib
and Abitalib. Of course, Alib
and Abhi Talib is his
son-in-law. Married to his
daughter, Fatima, Amir And his
first son was at Hessan. Right?
So, his al Hasan. However, one
day, the Ali Radi Allah got
into a spat with his wife
Fatima basically said, you know
what? I don't need this. I'm
going to the Masjid. So, he
just went to sleep at the
Masjid at night. So, the
prophet came looking for him at
the Masjid and of course, the
Masjid, the the ground, it
wasn't carpet this. It's
just dirt ground, right? So, he
found him laying in the masjid
and he said, right? So, he
referred to him as Abu Tarab,
meaning father of the dirt. So,
it's just something that
happen right? Something that an
incident that occurred, they
may get acuna from that, right?
This is permissible but the
kunya cannot be something that
over exalts a person that puts
down a person or that describes
a person to something that is,
that is undesirable, right?
This is part of the respect of
Alcuna. Do we have Kunyas in
the Quran? Is there a Kunya
mentioned in the Quran? Can you
think of one? Abu Lahab. Abu
Lahab is a Kunya, right?
What is Lehab? What does Lahab
mean?
No, no, no, just the, just the
word, what does it mean? Fire,
right? Lehab is is fire,
flames, you know. And the
scholars differ on why he was
referred to as Abu Lahab.
what's most mentioned by the
scholars of is that he was
referred to as Abu Lahab
because he had very fair skin.
Very fair skin. So, his face
was very red usually. Wasn't
tanned. Usually people that
live in the desert, their skin
is going to become leather
and very dark and brown, right?
But Abu Lahab was a very rich
man. He was part of the
nobility of Quraish. He doesn't
go out in the sun, right? He's
always in shade. So, he had
very fair skin and when he'd
get angry, his his face would
become very red and he's
referred to as Abu Lahab. This
is Acuna, right?
So, Abu Hakam is a Kunya.
That's not a permissible Kunya.
Who was called and referred to
as Abu Hakam? Abu Jahal. Abu
Jahal's what does Jahal
mean? Ignorance, right? He is
referred to as Abu Jahal.
Father of ignorance. That's not
his. His original Kunya was
Abul Hakam, the father of
wisdom. Immense wisdom.
However, the prophet prohibited
that a person be referred to as
Abul Hakam. He said in All
Allah is the hackam. It's not
permissible to have a of
because that's one of the names
of Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Also, that was not a befitting
kunya for Abu Jahal. and this
man that disbelieved in the
prophet and carried this
vendetta against him and fought
against him and hindered people
from the path of Allah would we
call him Abu Abu Hacham the
father of immense wisdom
Obviously not. This is not
befitting. So the prophet
coined him as Abu Jahal.
Another name that is
impermissible is Hazen. Hazen.
Hazen is an obstruction in your
path. have a barrier or
something that's obstructing
your path that's called the say
this path is very hazen meaning
that it's a path that has a lot
of obstructions in it this is
not a permissible name Also,
which we discussed and is a
person who is laying down
laying down. It's not a very
productive name, right?
The
Now the now he's discussing
names of places. Right? Now,
he's discussing names of places
One of these names is Sherbil
Balala, the valley of
misguidance. It's not a good
name to give a valley. The
valley of misguidance. Also,
Yathad was a name that he later
prohibited. This is the
original name of Medina. Do we
see a pattern here? We see a
pattern, right? That is that
any name that articulates
something foul or articulate
something that is not the value
of the Muslims. This is
considered a name which is
impermissible. Or a name which
is overly
overly virtuous. Right? Or a
name that is the name of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The names
of Allah divided into two
categories in this respect. You
have a category that is
impermissible to give to any
other person. Allah,
Rahman, right? Al Khalaq. These
are names which are specific to
Allah. Nobody can be named with
these names. there are other
names which can, which which
can restrictively be used for
other people, such as, such as,
right? Allah's name is Al
Mutman. So, can you name
Muttman? Another name is Rahim.
Allah's name is Al Rahim. The
most merciful. However, you can
name Rahim. Rahim without the
elephant, the lamb, right? This
is a restrictive use of the
names of Allah and it is
permissible. Oftentimes, when
someone is named Abdul Rahim,
for instance, people will refer
to him as Rahim or his name is
Abdul Kareem. They will refer
to him as Kareem. However,
sometimes a person's name is
Abdul Rahman. Can we call him
Rahman? No, it's a restrictive
name of Allah, right? Abdul
Khalik, can we call him Khalek?
No, this is a restrictive name
of Allah. What about Abdul Raza
[Silence]
and he disliked going to places
that had bad names or ominous
names He disliked even passing
through those areas if he could
at all help it. Then Abdul Kaim
Rahim mentions a narration
collected by
mentioned by in his book
that the prophet was on a
journey going to or from a
battle and he came upon two
mountains that he wanted to
pass between them in the valley
of these two mountains. He
asked what these mountains were
named, what they're called. So,
they told him these mountains
are named Falda and Mukhi. All
Bahmin someone who exposes
another person, right? Exposes
something bad about that person
and means someone who puts
another to shame. So, the names
of these mountains are
father and very ominous names
so the prophet did not go
between these two mountains in
that valley and he chose
another path. We have this in
names in English as well and I
believe in every language,
right? To have Devil's
Creek or Hell's Kitchen or
Hell's Gate, right? Or you'll
have, you know, the valley of
horrors or something that.
These these oh there's a valley
in the Nahani Valley. There's a
mountain in the Nahani Valley
in Canada which is referred to
as the Valley of the Headless
Men. Right? The Valley of the
Headless Men. Cuz people would
go there and camp and people
would find them later deceased
with their heads missing. It's
actually a true story. The
point is is that when areas or
places have this kind of name
prophet would avoid these
places. Why? Because
names have an effect on their
on their place and the place
has an effect on the name. A
person is usually given a
nickname or a place is given a
name or coined with a nickname
because of something that
happened there or something
that does happen or something
that is ominous about that
place. And so he would avoid
these places if at all
possible.
Al with the
[Silence]
is, whatever you choose for
your children's name. That's
the name that everyone is going
to see and hear on the day of
resurrection. And that's the
person is going to be called
forth for their judgments based
you know and they're going to
be introduced by that name. So,
we should make it a point to
choose best names.
The
[Silence]
ad name your children with my
name but do not give a with my
was Abu Qasim, right? So, he
encouraged the companions to
name their children by his
name, Muhammad. But then noone
was allowed to have the Kunya
Abu Qam except for him. Why is
this? This is something that is
specific. To the era of the
prophet A person has the today
of Abu Qasim, that's fine. But
in the time of the prophet this
was avoided. Why? Because the
companions they would address
the prophet by his they would
not address him by his name.
That they would not refer to
him as, you know, oh Muhammad.
They wouldn't call to him like
that. They wouldn't address him
with his first name. That was,
that's very bad manners. They
would address by his kunya. It
would say messenger of Allah,
prophet of Allah, they would
say and so if if other people
had this of Abu Kasim, right?
Other people had this of Abul
Qasim. then it might happen a
person will be placed in a
position where they may say Abu
Kasim intending someone else
the prophet would answer and
the person would be forced to
say no I didn't want you. I
wanted someone else. This is
not appropriate speech with the
prophet So, this was something
that was impermissible during
his lifetime.
Ibn is of the view that it is
impermissible to have the of
Abul Qasim during his lifetime
or after and we've discussed
that topic. Another issue we'd
to touch on with regards
to names and changing names.
When a person would accept
Islam, become Muslim in the
time of the prophet He would
off and ask them what their
name is and if they had a name
these names that we've
mentioned, he would change it
for them, right? So, for
instance, if a person's name
was Hazen, which means very
difficult road or path that is
full of obstructions, he would
change the person's name to
sell. Which is the opposite,
ease, easy road, unobstructed,
right? Likewise, if a person's
name was something that was
haram, something that was
particular to idolaters like
Abdul Shems, right? Abdul
Shems, the servant or slave of
the sun because people worship
the sun, right? He would change
this name to Abdullah or Abdul
Rahman, right?
and
This is something that people
have misunderstood with regards
to people accepting Islam. But
for instance, here in America,
we come from a predominantly
Christian country for the most
part. People are under the are
under the oppression that if a
person becomes Muslim, they
have to change their name.
Person becomes Muslim, they
have to change their name to an
Arabic name. That's not
necessarily correct. As long as
the name is not something bad,
right? The person's name is
onic or demon or something like
that. That's not a permissible
name too to have or the name is
not specific to non Muslims.
What do I mean by that? Like
Paul. Paul is what what kind of
name is that? He's a Christian
name, right? There's only
Christians use that name, Paul.
It's a reference to Paul of the
Bible, right? Which for some
reason is revered. This name is
not permissible for a Muslim to
have because that's a name
specific to non Muslims. Like
Mark. Mark is a Christian name,
right? Or Uzi. Uzi is a is a
Jewish name, right? It means
power in Hebrew. This is this
is specific to non Muslims.
Okay? We would not give these
names a person who has this
name would change their name.
But if a person has a a just a
regular name that's not
specific to any particular
religion. Right? person's name
is John or a person's name is
Alex or something that is just
a general name for people in
the English language, they
don't have to change their name
and they they actually
shouldn't change their name in
this case because it only
further and only further
distances people from Islam
being assimilated into society.
I mean, Islam is a religion
that goes into all places and
it adopts the best of that
culture and purges the worst of
that culture. This is what
Islam does and so, when people
become Muslim in America and
they have names that are
American names, this is fine.
As long as it's not a name,
that means something bad. Or as
a name, that, is is specific to
non Muslims.
[Silence]
Let me send me Ahad.
enough for tonight.